this morning at least one American ally
Germany is applauding the decision not
to attack Iran's ambassador to the UN
says Iran does not seek war Charlie
d'Agata is in the United Arab Emirates
not far from Iran Charlie what else is
Iran saying good morning well Iran
remains defiant today insisting once
again that they've got indisputable
evidence that that drone crossed over
into their airspace and these images
just released from state TV showing a
Revolutionary Guard surveying jagged
pieces of metal said to be debris from
the drone recovered from their own
territorial waters that's important
there are also reports quoting Iranian
officials the president Trump gave a
warning overnight via a third country
that an attack on Iran was imminent
however an Iranian official tells CBS
News that communication never took place
now the downing of the drone and
possible retaliation has prompted the
FAA to ban all US airlines over some
Iranian airspace news that has since
been followed by half a dozen
international carriers and Counting now
as for the possibility of talks Iran's
UN Ambassador is quoted as saying you
cannot negotiate with someone who has a
knife in his hand and he's holding that
knife to your throat
Tony Charlie d'Agata Forest in the
United Arab Emirates Charlie thank you
very much